la première sous-gouverneur de la banque
du canada caroline wilkins et à montréal
elle a prononcé ce midi un discours au
cercle de la finance internationale de
montréal pour parler des mesures en
place pour protéger le système financier
canadien avec nous ce soir car les
noyaux qui est notre invité ce week-end
mais c'est fini toujours un plaisir de
vous accueillir sur notre plateau vous
avez dit aujourd'hui dans votre
conférence que le contexte international
s'est détériorée ce qui augmente les
risques pour la croissance mondiale
ainsi que les possibilités de tension
financière quels sont les risques qui
pèsent présentement selon vous sur
l'économie mais vraiment deux choses
d'une part et à l'incertitude qui
entoure le commerce extérieur avec la
guerre commerciale entre les états unis
et les chaînes
ça cause beaucoup de problèmes pour les
autres entreprises avoir une stratégie
pour naviguer tout ça et en même temps
on vit dans un monde où il ya beaucoup
de dettes
enfin il use de dette par rapport au pib
mondial qu'on avait pendant la grande
récession sur ce que j'ai vu ça dans
votre discours aujourd'hui j'en suis
parvenu car quand on dit que le niveau
d'endettement et trois fois le pib
mondial
c'est ça la dette mondiale représente
trois fois le pib mondial plus qu'avant
la grande récession est ce qu'on doit
s'inquiéter de sa basse et dépend de la
qualité de la dette donc il y en a
beaucoup qui sont lents pour faire les
investissements qui vont faire croître
l'économie mondiale donc ça c'est une
bonne chose ou s'inquiète c'est que si
jamais on a des craintes que la qualité
de ses dettes leur est moindre et se
détériore et six exactement pour ça que
je j'ai un crainte que que l'on voit au
niveau de l'endettement par exemple les
sociétés non financières qui a une telle
détérioration soit autant dans les pays
avancés que dans les pays émergents mais
vous ne prévoyez pas de récession
on ne priverait on ne prévoit pas une
récession pense pas que c'est la chose
la plus improbable mais comme tout
gestionnaire de risques c'est notre job
et légendes d'alsace de tout le monde de
se préparer
juste au cas où juste au cas où mais
juste au cas où
le niveau de risque il est élevé jusqu'à
quel point qu'on a une récession
mondiale qu'on a une récession au canada
par exemple
mais comme je vous dis c'est pas notre
projection de tout en ce moment puisque
pendant les projections des autres non
plus en général c'est sûr que c'est ce
que si jamais une augmentation de
d'incertitude ou un autre choc qui
pourrait déclencher une ralentissement
est plus prononcé qu'on existe déjà mais
ça pourrait causer le problème mais
comme j'ai dit aujourd'hui le système
financier au canadien est prêt un tel
événement et vous dites aussi ce que
vous avez dit aujourd'hui c'est que s'il
ya un ralentissement grave de l'économie
mondiale ça pourrait faire en sorte que
le canada serait touchée très durement
quels sont les risques que ça se
produise cela mais ce qui arrive quand
il ya un ralentissement au niveau
mondial c'est que la demande pour les
exportations du menu et aussi les prix
des matières premières qu on vend deux
autres diminue aussi et c'est pour cette
raison-là conquois qu'on pourrait être
touchée et quand on vit dans un contexte
où les ménages ici au canada au niveau
de l'aide quand même assez élevé mais ça
fait les effets plus prononcé et c'est
pour ça qu'on fait les études de stress
pour justement voir comment le système
financier au canada subit un tel choc
et on voit que on aime bien bien placé
on est bien placés en face à un choc un
choc économique un choc financier une
nouvelle crise financière est ce qu'on
est bien protégé de cela mais je veux
pas parler de nouvelle crise c'est une
question hypothétique
ah mais en même temps on peut penser que
que
il pourrait avoir une renoncement plus
prononcé pour ça au mois d'octobre qu'on
est sorti le rapport sur la politique
monétaire
on a fait un tel scénario et dans ce
contexte là on voit que la croissance
diminue
l'inflation du mignon aussi mairesse mme
entre nos noms notre fourchette cible et
on voit aussi que le système financier
est en mesure de le subir
oui et on a les outils aussi et on a les
outils pour se protéger le niveau
d'endettement des ménages vous l'avez
dit élevé au canada plus élevé qu'en
2008 n'est ce pas si l'économie ralentit
s'est sérieusement quels sont les
risques pour les ménages canadiens
mais ce qui arrive quand l'économie
ralentit et que d'une part des fois les
taux d'intérêt sont moins élevés donc
les gens qui renouvellent leur
hypothèque mais ils vont avoir une
augmentation de paiement qui peut être
moindre que ce soir et était mais en
même temps au niveau des revenus sa peau
réelles ça pourrait être un chantre pour
certaines gens qui perdent leur emploi
oui peut-être de façon temporaire mais
quand même c'est un question de comment
pouvoir naviguer ça et c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit aujourd'hui que c'est la
première ligne de défense est vraiment
les entreprises et les ménages pour
évaluer leurs propres risques et les
mitigé oui
dans votre rapport dans votre discours
aujourd'hui que dans votre rapport
récent la banque du canada vous dites
que lee ménages fortement endetté
emprunte de plus en plus sur le plan
hypothécaires et quand on dit fortement
endetté c'est des ménages qui ont un une
dette qui représente 450 % de leur
revenu également ce qui très élevé ce
qui est trésor ce qui est très endetté
est ce qu'il ya un danger de ce côté là
compte tenu que ces ménages endettés
sans doute davantage mais ce qu'il a ce
qu'on a vu depuis depuis quelques années
c'est que l'un
règlements qui sont plus strictes au
niveau des prêts hypothécaires donc le
test de stress fait en sorte qu on a la
qualité de nouveau aux hypothèques est
pas mal plus élevé qu'avant la crise
alors la proportion de gens qui sont
très endettés comme vous dites de plus
de 45% de leur revenus à et 450 livres
les leviers 400 oui cca évidemment il y
en a beaucoup moins donc on a vu ces
règlements plus stricts ont fait leur
effet voulu c'est de protéger le système
financier mais aussi protéger protéger
les gens à contre une situation où ils
ont trop de dettes
on parle beaucoup de toronto et de
vancouver mais est-ce qu'on commence à
la banque du canada à regarder de près
le marché immobilier de montréal et le
marché de l'endettement hypothécaire de
montréal la grande région de montréal
mais on regarde toutes les villes au
canada et ce qui nous nous intéresse
étant donné qu'on cible d'inflation
globale et l'économie globale et le
marché immobilier dans son ensemble mais
c'est vrai que on a porté beaucoup
d'attention à vancouver et toronto plus
parce que le taux d'augmentation des
prix a commencé pas mal élevés et
c'était c'est 30% dans un délai le
moment donné alors et puis on a vu
qu'ils avaient plus de spéculation ce
qu'on voit à montréal en ce moment c'est
vraiment une économie qui roulent très
très bien le taux de chômage est bas il
ya beaucoup de gens qui rentrent à
montréal qui veut vivre ici alors avec
une demande sous jacente qui très forte
au niveau d'offre qui qui est limité
mais on pourrait s'attendre d'avoir les
augmentations de prix et jusqu'à date
que je vois les augmentations de prix
n'atteignent pas du tout les
netto qu'on a vu à toronto ou vancouver
merci madame ou dickens merci beaucoup
s'intégrant plaisir si bien
[Musique]